when you're setting up a movie like this
or a number of conversations you're
going to have to have one is with Marcus
who has written a book and the other one
is with the families whose sons died on
this mission I'm curious how those
conversations are both the same and
different it wasn't it wasn't a it
wasn't a big pitch you know Marcus isn't
like a pitch guy you know pretty
no-nonsense gentleman and he obviously
was very close to this material and so
the the pitch really consisted of he was
in LA he'd met a bunch of filmmakers was
about to leave I read the book in one
day while we're filming a read almost
all of it and enough to know that I
wanted to meet him and we asked him to
come down and visit us on the set of
Hancock he came down for about an hour
he didn't really say much and I didn't
know what to say so I finally just kind
of said let me excuse me show you a
rough cut of the kingdom which was in
still in hadn't quite wasn't quite
finished I said if you like it and you
want to stay I'll have dinner with you
and and you know try and give you a
pitch if not nice to meet you and he saw
it and liked it and we had dinner and
after that dinner he agreed to let us do
it and then you have to go to the
families I assume as s Pete starts
writing we did we went and visited the
deets Murphy and axelsson families in
their hometowns really just to tell them
our intentions what we wanted to do with
this movie and how we wanted to honor
their sons and the extent to
particularly Pete's but all of our
commitment to getting the details right
and making it an authentic portrayal of
their bravery and that was you know kind
of a consistent conversation and I think
the families were very warm and open
with us from the beginning but also
adamant that we get this story right and
and do justice to how their sons died so
that was a pledge we made to them very
early on mark you know that doing
justice and that's a tall order and I
know
every rule that you consider doing and
choose doing there's going to be a mix
of excitement and caution with a
different equation for this story and
taking on this kind of material and
dealing with this story absolutely I
mean initially you know I just peek kind
of gave me a one-liner pitch about you
know what a great opportunities as an
actor and of course you know my own
selfish reasons I was like yes I get to
go through all this and I'm the only one
who makes it and then when I read and I
goes oh my god forget that this is just
I'm lucky to be a part of something
that's so much more important than my
own personal interest in the project and
but then I felt you know obviously a
huge overall amount of responsibility in
making sure that we got it right but the
great thing is is every single person
involved in the project both in front of
and behind the camera felt that same
responsibility in that commitment to
getting it right and within that
responsibility how do you create a
performance that's not to rely on what
you know about Marcus and who he is as a
person you try not to engage with him
too much maybe meet him say hello and
then go off and find the character on
your own um well the source the source
material gave you enough information but
of course wanting Marcus to be involved
inviting him into the process to
whatever extent he wanted to be involved
but he's not the kind of guy who's just
opens up that quickly either you have to
kind of earn his trust in his respect so
it wasn't like I wanted to use him when
I wanted him and kind of pushed him away
I keep him at arm's length when it was
convenient for me because this was about
them so as soon as I earned his trust
and respect and I could kind of slowly
start to ask him questions but I never
really wanted to cross the line and I
definitely felt like there was a line
there and if there was something that he
was comfortable talking about with and I
would kind of let him kind of open the
conversation if was some that he wasn't
I would certainly wouldn't cross those
boundaries but I'm still unfortunate
enough throughout the entire process of
after making the moving going on talking
about them are we getting to know Marcus
as a man and he's a very very special
individual unlucky to know him do you
watch this movie differently than you
watch other performances based on what
you know about Marcus and based on who
he is I every time I come to something
where we're screening the movie are
going to do a Q&A talk about it I
purposely watched the last 30 minutes or
so of the movie and I've never been able
to kind of sit there and say oh we did
this so we could have done that I just
think about what those guys experienced
on that
he'll and and that's you know it's it
I've never experienced that before any
other movie that I've been involved with
Pete the the book there are so many
places so many ways you could tell the
story there's obviously a lot of
backstory and training kind of the whole
mythology of seals before he gets on the
mountain with the three guys in adapting
the book did you feel pretty strongly
that you wanted to get there as fast as
possible did you consider you know
shooting training all that or did you
wanted to start as soon as you could
with what happened there were kind of
three different chapters in the book or
the book was I think sort of divided up
into three different experiences one was
a very thorough explanation and
revisiting of how the Navy SEAL
selection process which is for anyone
that doesn't know I'm sure you guys have
all heard it it's not easy to become a
Navy Seal and that's an understatement
and Marcus spends a lot of time talking
about just how hellacious that
experience was and how that Brotherhood
is forged out of adversity and pain and
suffering and real real friendship and
that kind of bond isn't forged out of
comfort and happiness and security and
so that the seal community has developed
this almost scientific program to
basically demolish human beings as
certainly physically and test their will
at the most you know profound at its
core and that was a big part of the book
and I thought that that was just almost
its own its own experience and so that's
what we just did the opening credit
sequence you know kind of late in the
game I thought that we could at least
touch upon what Latrell talked about and
hopefully give an audience some idea of
how these guys could actually do what
they did how they could fall off those
cliffs how they could survive Danny
Dietz was shot 11 times I mean I read
his autopsy report and he kept kept
going and and there's there's a reason
you know but people have asked me is
that real could they really do it and
these men are extraordinary and they
have
a chip for lack of a better word that I
certainly don't have you probably do
have it you never know that's one of the
funny things about it in fact you never
ever know when I was observing my first
hell week the two guys that were always
way out in front one was this big kind
of Brad Pitt looking guy you know six
foot three his father was a congressman
he was at Annapolis this kind of golden
child and he was way out in front and
the guy that was always right on his
heels was this little five-foot-one
Spanish kid who'd worked for domino's
pizza and the Bronx and the two of them
want everything and that was my first
relevant you never know who's so that
was a part of the book that didn't make
it as much and then the other part was
Marcus talked a lot about the vigil that
was going back at his mother's ranch in
Texas which is really fascinating you
know hundreds and hundreds of people
came and sort of did this 67 day vigil
as they were waiting to hear whether he
was dead or alive and he talked a lot
about that and to me that that was a
very interesting part of the story but I
wanted to focus on on the what happened
on that mountain and what you know put
mark through what Marcus had gone to and
have you had a chance to talk to the
families after they've seen the film or
showing it to them what was that
experience like Sarah we did very early
on after we lock the cut we invited
universal i should say flew all the
families the the deets Christensen's
shane patents family the Murphy's and
the axle sins to a theater at universal
to show them the movie because it was
important to us that they see it first
with us in a safe environment and be
able to tell us what they thought about
it and as you can imagine one of
absolutely the most nerve-racking
moments of my life really and I think we
were quite anxious about it and you know
Pete said it's true we had a therapist
there a military therapist trained to
deal with families and grief to be there
for counseling afterwards and
the family members were at the end of
the movie very moved very touched but
also very thankful clear from the second
you know the lights came up that we had
done a good job and so that meant
everything to us we were both very
rattled we could barely when the play
together when mrs. axelsson the you know
the mother of the shielded Ben Foster
plays she said okay on behalf of the
families we want to say we approve of
this and we we bless this film and then
I started crying real hard because I had
kept it in for so long and then I had
the grief therapist on me thought on me
and I'm like and then I had the missus
teach and mrs. axelsson comforting me
and I'm like I'm like you know we had
kept this in for quite a while and we
were scared of how the families were
going to respond and knowing that if you
know in this day and age it would only
take one family member to say you know
this is unacceptable this is offensive
and you know put that online and it
would have been very upsetting to us so
it was unique we've never had that kind
of weird pressure you know that was very
very intense and it was a great relief
to show it show it to the families and
have them not you know to give us that
support